[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais enfourché mon balai
pour vous présenter l'équipe des aides
l'essonne qui est basée ici aux
clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
pour nous présenter ce sport insolite je
suis aux côtés de gilles qui est père
fondateur qui est également coach joueur
qui fait un peu tout ici alors gilles
qu'est ce que c'est ce sport alors le
quidditch et en fait c'est un patchwork
des différents sports on a le rugby pour
les contacter on a le handball pour la
forme du tir on a le cardio beaucoup de
cardio parce qu'il faut savoir que le
terrain qui est derrière nous fait quand
même 44 mètres de long pour 33 de large
donc ce qui est assez long et on peut
aller marquer derrière comme devant au
niveau des buts et on a aussi le ballon
prisonnier donc le dodgeball donc on a
des ballons de football qu'on se tire
royalement dessus donc sert là c'est un
sport de tout ça c'est un mélange de ça
et c'est un port mixte on le voit
derrière il n'y a pas de balle et un
c'est un bâton quels sont les autres
différences avec la saga harry potter et
ce sport qui est devenu un vrai sport
oui c'est devenu un vrai sport en fait
il ya une coupe de france et une coupe
d'europe et une coupe d'europe des
nations il ya une coupe du monde que les
etats-unis ont gagné contre la belgique
en italie avant de coheed donc là il ya
une nouvelle qui devrait arriver donc la
france est sélectionné donc elle va y
aller aussi donc cocorico mais oui ben
en fait tout est différent le ballet on
ne veulent pas on court avec les ballons
de deux ball les ballons de les cogneurs
laisser devenus des ballons de football
le soin fait un ballon volé dégonfler
qu'on peut tenir une main et en fait
c'est une sorte de contrainte d'avoir le
ballet parce qu'il faut toujours avoir
une main dessus ou d'avoir toujours
entre les jambes si on l'a pas on est
obligé de toucher ses cages il ya
également le vif d'or je crois qui
apparaît en deuxième partie de match si
je peux dire quasiment on va dire
presque à la fin parce que ça arrive à
la 18e minute donc et à partir de la 18e
minute on a donc un joueur qui vient
avec le familles soucieuses sorte jaune
que j'ai là avec une balle de tennis
dans une chaussette et le but c'est
d'attraper le vif d'or sans toucher le
joueur donc c'est un peu compliqué et
ils ont voulu tester aux états unis avec
un drone mais ça n'a pas fait long feu
le drone a été cassée directement après
ces explications sur ce sport place à
l'entraînement je vais tester ces
disciplines
[Musique]
là on est bon voilà la même si tu
t'écartes un peu c'est pas grave par
contre si vraiment tu commences à sortir
là tu es considéré tomber c'est comme si
tu étais touché par un cognard donc
ballet au dessus de la tête tu vas
toucher tebbutt et après je crois bien
encore monter sur ton d'aller hockey
[Musique]
ah oui c'est physique
j'ai testé j'approuve ce sport le
quidditch il ya environ 400 licenciés
enfoncé une quarantaine de clubs
maintenant c'est à vous d'essayer